Katy Perry fires a new shot plus fifth
harmony is not quite ready for the VMAs
it is shaping up to be a very
interesting weekend we're just days away
from the MTV Video Music Awards with
Katy Perry hosting of course and Taylor
Swift also drop in some new music this
weekend it is a battle for domination
meanwhile we were with one of VMAs top
acts fifth harmony the ladies are
teasing their big performance with Katy
Kraus and guess what I got a treat for
ya
Katy's here to the Daily nei Katy you
were backstage with the girls what do
they have up their sleeve alright well
let me tell you Harmonizers are in for a
treat the ladies told me that they are
performing down yes and that there will
be different elements and surprises
they also teased it's a moment that will
have people gagging yeah that's a weird
way to describe it right go for it yeah
here's the catch though they still do
not know what they're wearing on stage
what about the costumes are we matching
are we going fierce you guys really
don't know really if this week couldn't
get any cooler or better you guys have
an album coming out Friday you co-wrote
so much of it what's the advantage to
writing your own songs and then
recording them honestly yeah being able
to connect with the music and just
recognizing that you actually believe in
what you're doing right and I feel like
we almost got we got our power back and
we learned to love music again just
because you know it reflects our voices
and we say
everything that we want to be able to
say and we know how we want it to sound
and we know that in 10 years it'll mean
what it means now to us I love them I do
love them yesterday so financially are
on a mission they also told me that they
want this record out Friday to be
something that they would be proud of
forever
they also teased a new tour movie could
be in the works
live more on that tomorrow ne T online
he has fifth harmony would say it but
you gotta put in work work work and
thank you for your work Katie where are
you guys another VMA performance sure to
get people talking is from this year's
host Katy Perry and she's a busy little
Katie cat she's rehearsing for her tour
prepping for Sunday's award show and she
just dropped the new video for her
supposed Taylor dis track swish swish 16
hours after Taylor announced she's
releasing a new single tonight
coincidence I think not it is game on
[Music]
get used to it
[Music]
[Applause]
swish all right I'm gonna keep it real
what is happening in this video I need
choreo I need mascot I need cheerleaders
I will say the best part of course is
Nicki Minaj because she came to slay
with that long hair come on
all right let's hope it's enough to
outshine Taylor Swift who is rumored to
be dropping a music video herself this
week will it Eclipse Katy Perry's big
VMA weekend time will tell meanwhile
another pop star feud is getting the
spotlight in a new documentary on
Netflix
Lady Gaga five-foot-two is a film about
a year in the life of the artist
formerly known as Stephanie Germanotta
and it will cover such things as her
stunning halftime show at this year's
Super Bowl and takes fans inside an
illness she's been dealing with for a
while now the doc premieres on September
22nd when she will also apparently spill
some tea on her famous dust-up with
Madonna which goes back a few years guys
as you can see in this short clip Gaga
shared on her Instagram the thing with
like me and Madonna for example is that
I admired her always and I still admire
her no matter what she might think of me
no I do yeah the only thing that really
bothers me about her yeah that clip it
cuts up before we get our answer I
imagine that's what a game of Thrones
cliffhanger feels like all right
obviously I am so here for this because
not only do I love Gaga but I love me a
good play by play of a celebrity fight
so I will be watching with popcorn and
3d glasses on meanwhile you know whose
life feels like it's in 4d right now
country star Thomas Rhett the singer and
his wife Lauren Atkins welcomed a
daughter ADA James just a couple weeks
ago the couple is also parents to Willa
Grey who they adopted in July from
Uganda
so how it's Thomas adjusting to life at
home with an infant while ours sophie
scholl AC found out no rest for you you
look great though you don't look tired
and I think with a new fad that's a big
compliment I appreciate that right off
the bat how is life with two little ones
at home right now it's pretty intense
because I kind of feel like when one of
them
goes to sleep the other one wakes up and
vice versa and but we're just we're
figuring out as we go and and it's been
it's been a fun journey thus far house
more and I saw her today she looks like
a rock star yeah I mean she's doing
amazing
besides being you know a little bit
sleep-deprived like we both are we're
both doing pretty good considering the
circumstances and so we're just you know
we're excited to kind of start to learn
how to be better better and better
parents everyday yeah he's probably more
sleep-deprived than he let on but you
wouldn't know it the man looks good all
right before we sign out today I know we
are in the middle of VMA mania but the
biggest night in TV is also just 24 days
away and you know first-time host
Stephen Colbert has some tricks up his
sleeve hi I'm Stephen Colbert and I'm
hosting the 2017 Emmy Awards you know
there's been a lot of hacking this year
so to ensure that the winners remain top
secret I've had my assistant place all
the envelopes in this giant safe you
okay in there
mmm only a couple more weeks cannot wait
for that the Emmys air live on CBS
Sunday September 17th and the daily Deni
airs every day at 3 p.m. on e t--'s
youtube channel so be sure to hit
subscribe and I'll have more for you
guys tomorrow music fighting cannot wait
see you then
yeah